bonjour bienvenue sur diagonale tv
spéciale grand champion de l'histoire du
jeu d'échecs avec giraumon france et le
giro 9 sél et stéphane alors aujourd'hui
on va voir non pas un champion mais une
championne et pas la moindre la plus
grande joueuse d'échecs de tous les
temps c'est le titre qu'elle mérite
il n'y a pas de chose qui lui soit
comparable dans l'histoire du jeu
d'échecs
on a déjà vu bien sûr et prendre
prédécesseurs comme vers amène chic on
pourrait situer toutes les joueuses
géorgienne mais c'est véritablement
judit polgar la plus forte joueuses de
tous les temps à telle enseigne qu elle
refuse de jouer les compétitions
féminines 1 2 jours refusé elle a
toujours refusé ça ne l'intéresse pas on
est en août 2012 l'année en train de
jouer les olympiades dans l'équipe mixte
de hongrie dont quatre jours elle joue
avec les hommes
elle ne joue pas dans les tournois
féminin et on dit plus grandes choses de
tous les temps on pourrait dire un des
plus grands joueurs aussi de l'ère
moderne puisque en 2003 elle était 10e
mondial avec un îlot de 1715 will qui la
place parmi les meilleurs joueurs de
l'histoire
voyez donc c'est là c'est la première
femme à avoir atteint le top 10 mondial
toutes catégories c'est comme si je
parlais au tennis on avait on avait eu
serena williams dans les dix meilleurs
mondiaux toutelatélé catégorie en train
de jouer face à federer bon alors je lui
dit a ceci de remarquable qu'elle en
plus elle a une carrière longue c'est à
dire qu'elle n'est pas elle n'est pas
allée pas arrivé sur le circuit hier
elle a atteint le titre d'abord quelque
chose d'exceptionnel kiki qui montre à
quel point c'est aussi toutes catégories
au delà des échecs féminin un des plus
grands joueurs de tous les temps mixtes
c'est à dire que parce qu'elle a obtenu
le titre de grand maître international à
15 ans et quelques mois en battant le
record de bobby fischer qui datait de
1958 et je crois que la map tu ce record
en 91 91
voilà c'est l'aîné en 1976 elle est pâle
est pas seul dans sa famille il ya deux
autres soeurs social souza qui sont
elles-mêmes joueuse d'échecs
on le verra sur sur des photographies et
elle se fait remarquer dès dès l'âge de
dix 10 11 ans à 12 ans elle joue déjà
les olympiades et ensuite elle obtient
rapidement le titre de grand maître
international à 15 ans donc c'est
extrêmement extrêmement précoce et puis
elle a poursuivi sa carrière dans les
années 90 bien sûr 2000 et continue
encore à jouer aujourd'hui elle a eu la
connu d'interruption qui était
parfaitement volontaire puisque en 2004
elle a eu un enfant
donc forcément ça l'a éloigné des
échiquiers ça aussi fait forcément on a
moins de disponibilité d'esprit quand on
a un enfant et qu'on doit s'organiser
mais elle a quand même fait un retour
remarqué dans le monde des échecs
récemment puisqu'elle a fini troisième
aux championnats d'europe avec ses 20
l'année dernière oui et donc la fille
aussi d'autres résultats en tournois
tout à fait exceptionnelle on peut je
crois qu'elle a fini une fois 2e du
tournoi de
deux cars est deuxième avec hands et en
2003 et est deuxième à linares en 2000
ce qui est exceptionnel c'est
détournement là où il y avait quand même
tout le monde le gratin mondial c'est à
dire que les normes l'etrat nickelés
kasparov et sait jouer c'est ronan là
c'est à dire que là elle a fait un
résultat qui est qui est tout à fait
exceptionnel hier c'est dommage elle n'a
pas encore réussi une victoire dans ce
tournoi mais mais très proches elle
avait terminé donc souvent qu'est ce
qu'on peut dire d'autre alors c'est
quand même l'histoire de vie paul garred
particulière puisque elle est issue
évidemment de la famille pôle gare et ce
sont ses parents qui ont décidé
finalement de
de donner une éducation juste
échiquéenne à leurs trois filles oui un
instant un petit peu des soeurs williams
au tennis lazlo polgar le père des trois
les trois soeurs décidé de les former
aux échecs et on a fait trois
championnes
bien sûr je luttais la plus forte mais
elles sont toutes les trois quand même
jouer des olympiades
il ya une période en 1988 à
thessalonique où l'équipe de hongrie
féminines s'étaient sofia judith souza
plus une quatrième joueuse ildiko voilà
c'était paul guerre contre le reste du
monde alors sur cette histoire là il
faut préciser que les parents paul
garçons psychologue est que cette
volonté de former leur fils au jeu
d'échecs n'est pas tombé du ciel comme
ça c'est à dire que il avait une
certaine approche de ce que devait être
l'éducation en tant que psychologue
d'entendre scientifique en fait comment
finalement à avoir des enfants qu'ils
puissent se réaliser et c'est hésiter
arrivé à la conclusion avec leurs
travaux qu'ils auraient pu faire sur
d'autres enfants en général que
finalement plus les enfants étaient
spécialisés tôt dans une matière plus
devenu brillant en fait dans cette
matière et il avait compris sa notamment
dans les sciences
c'était clair pour eux qu'en
mathématiques en physique c'est ce sont
les enfants qui la prend là prennent le
plus tôt qui finalement en général
deviennent les plus brillants derrière
donc il ya une notion de précocité et
ils ont voulu finalement plus que par
mettre à l'épreuve leur leur leurs idées
ne pas forcément uniquement les les
écrire mais les mettre à l'épreuve de
l'expérience et ils ont décidé de le
faire pour le jeu d'échec parce qu'il
disait au moins aux échecs on aura un
classement et on pourra vérifier si ça
marche parce que en matant physique bon
obtenir un prix nobel c'est très
aléatoire mais aux échecs on peut
vérifier que ça fonctionne alors ils ont
décidé de donner une éducation qui
tiennent à leurs trois filles qu'ils ont
eu successivement dans cette optique là
et ça a marché pour les trois faut dire
que l'on parle de vue dit mais on peut
évidemment et on est obligé en parlant
du dit de parler de susa et de soufia
bien sûr que qui ont toutes les deux
aussi une carrière
si vous aviez aux états unis maintenant
elle continue à être très active
disputent des tournois puis avec
plusieurs titres de champion du monde
plusieurs titres de championne du monde
féminine puisque je voulais titre i les
tournois féminins sofia joue peut-être
un petit peu avant que d'autres là je
crois arrêté mais en tout cas elles ont
toutes les trois ont réussi un temps
donné raison à leurs parents au moins
sur ce plan parce qu'elles ont toutes
les trois atteint un niveau
international
oui et alors pour sur sophia quand même
juste une remarque parce que suzanne
elle a été multipliée du monde donc on
pourra voir le palmarès est pas de
problème avec ça sur sophia même si elle
a arrêté c'est vrai que ça a été
considérable peut-être comme la plus
talentueuse détroit mais c'est justement
et c'est là un peu dévie vers
l'artistique plutôt faire de la fée la
peinture en fait maintenant apparemment
mais à noter quand même que à l'âge de
de 14 15 ans je sais plus exactement
l'âge exact
elle a fait le tournoi de rome sofia je
crois que c'était en 89 quelque chose
comme ça et elle a réussi là une des
plus grandes performances et lot de tous
les temps puisqu'elle a fait une
performance de 2950 ont plus qu
absolument extraordinaire elle a fait je
crois que c'était 8 et me sur 9
devant le parterre de grands maîtres et
de mettre et on voit la gamine de vin
avec la coupe et tout lé tout le vieux
briscard derrière un peu dépité de
s'être fait écraser comme ça par sofia
polga voilà donc les trois soeurs et me
judith est la plus brillante sans aucun
doute des 3 et elle a donné maille à
partir au plus grand champion de la
planète alors on va voir quelques photos
de l'activité chicken de judit polgar
alors d'abord cette première photo est
donc elle est à gauche on la reconnaît
bien sûr elle est ici face à vichy
allende le champion du monde actuel
voilà train de jouer face au champion du
monde avec son drapeau en droit alors
c'est cette photographie illustrant fait
un match organisé un mayence en 2008 je
crois entre la femme le plus fort du
monde et l'homme le plus fort du monde
c'était un double le pitch de
l'événement voilà sofia jeudi pardon
mais quand même une tradition chicken
forte en hongrie 1
oui on pourrait citer notamment un pâle
bengo oui alors bien sûr
braselton rugby et ainsi de suite et
picard l'écho bien sûr à l'hôpital cook
a aussi fait une finale de championnat
du monde sa chronique et qui d'ailleurs
n'a pas perdu et ça s'est terminé un
match nul c'était c'était un peu c'était
s'était envolé la hongrie a une grande
tradition et chicken et de très fort
joueur dont évidemment
donc je dis tu fais partie quoi
au niveau hongrois mais au niveau aussi
mondiale voilà donc deuxième photo ici
de judith en train de réfléchir en vue
d'un homme en train de préparer son coup
sûr une partie d'échecs
voilà ici une troisième toujours assez à
mayence 9e toujours voilà une troisième
partie on note sur l'échiquier qu'il est
connecté ici c'est un échiquier
électronique évidemment et qui permet de
récupérer les coûts automatiquement sans
besoin de les noter je suis dit qu'il
prépare son prochain coup alors ça a été
un grand malheur d'apprendre le mariage
de judit polgar je pense qu'il ya eu
beaucoup parce que je dis tu as beaucoup
de fans parce que le monde échiquéen
quand même mandats c'est assez masculin
et qui reste quand même assez masculin
avec une très forte progression des
femmes ces dernières années de plus en
plus de féminines qui joue et qui si
sans doute pas étranger d'ailleurs au
succès du dipôle hier qu'il peut se
vident amants se reconnaître dans le
parcours le succès de judit polgar et
donc quand une femme réussit finalement
ça fait plaisir en france les
aficionados du jeu apprécié ça surtout
world élite en plus un jeu magnifique
c'est une grande attaquante un jeu qui
fait le plaisir à voir et à suivre et il
y avait sans doute beaucoup de fan
d'échecs qui était un peu amoureux
d'elle par procuration elle a épousé
quelqu'un qui n'a rien à voir avec le
monde des échecs puisque son mari et
vétérinaire jeunes ont exactement est
tout à fait que c'est juste et hongrois
et on voit l'un n'empêche pas l'autre
donc il fallait être on voit donc ce
qu'il t'est pas morts ils peuvent se
consoler
donc ici alors une dernière photo alors
qui est floue mais qui est importante
puisque c'est une photo où les trois
soeurs pour le gard sont réunis au sein
de l'équipe hongroise
qui représentait les clippers et
l'équipe féminine où ses équipes toutes
catégories
non c'est l'équipe féminine donc je
pense que c'est la seule photo de judit
polgar joints de compétition féminine
elle à la 12 ans qu'elle remonterait
jeunes malades 12 ans et à thessalonique
en 1980 81 88 cm est allé avec ses trois
soeurs donc l'équipe de l'engrais est
constitué les 300 pôle gare de gauche à
droite donc on à sofia ait pu en rouge
on à judith et envers tout à droite on à
souza et la joueuse qui englobe péricaud
et elle est la quatrième donc en fait
c'est quasiment les 300 premières qui
constituent l'équipe féminine des
olympiades de langue green c'est un fait
unique dans l'histoire
oui je ne crois pas qu'ils aient déjà eu
comme ça il fera prix ni chez les hommes
ni chez les femmes qui à ce point puisse
représenter son pays
exact voilà et enfin alors ici on a
montré alors c'est pas je vous dit c'est
mais pour montrer quand même que c'est
aussi une famille donc de champion on a
ici une photo de susa polgar la soeur
aînée
celle qui a défriché le terrain pour les
autres parce que je dit elle-même
indique évidemment le fait que suse à
son aînée elle même est déjà
l'expérience du jeu l'a beaucoup aidée à
progresser beaucoup plus vite
puisqu'elle de s'entraîner entre elles à
noter d'ailleurs que les soeurs paul
garon
reçus bobby fischer lui même chez eux à
budapest
il a passé du temps en hongrie et ils
ont pu ils ont pu parler avec lui
elles ont pu le rencontrer il a eu un
petit contact avec avec les soeurs les
soeurs au pôle gare qui lui même avait
fait des déclarations très sympathique à
l'encontre des joueurs d'échecs et dans
les années soixante dix en disant qu'il
était capable de jeu contre n'importe
quel jeu en lui laissant davantage d'une
pièce ou à l'époque
à l'époque je pense pas qu'il aurait
même au top de sa forme je pense pas
qu'il serait permis de laisserai ne
serait-ce qu'un pion à judit polgar à
ses flux pareil c'est plus pareil c'est
fait la même histoire
voilà donc on va en revient sur le
plateau qui on va passer à notre parti
du jour puisque nous allons voir
maintenant une partie entre anatoli
karpov et judit polgar qui a lieu à alma
ata c'est un blitz entre le champion du
monde et judit polgar qui démarre ici
par le coup de karpov c4 voilà le
l'ouverture ici de ce blitz une lance
une très belle partie d'attac cavaliers
6 noeuds la part de visites qu'a laissé
3g 6 j'ai trois fous g7 donc on est dans
une ouverture de type estonienne alors
qu'une pas beaucoup joué cet alien
jouer un peu un peu la fischer c'est
peut-être pour ça aussi que ou apprécié
son style de jeu il est extrêmement
agressif c'est une ouverture qui va être
agressive elle a joué l'estonienne et
beaucoup la sicilienne les débuts ouvert
voilà c'est son style de jeu d'attaqué
vraiment un jeu d'attaqué donc ici
maintenant fou j'ai deux des six
normales tout scénariste ignore si nice
tiennent pour les blancs avec un début
symétriquement soi même le fou enfin
kito ce donc ce sont des estoniennes un
peu plus positionnelle un peu plus lente
un peu moins un peu moins agressive que
les estoniennes plus classique où les
blancs développe tout de suite sur
cavalière f3 puis le fond le 2 qui donne
d'autres types de parties donc d4 petit
rock
quels livres 3 calais b 17
tout ça est normal s'est classé dans
cette position generali dans sept types
de d'ouverture pour les blancs les noirs
mettre leurs cavaliers en 17 et prépare
la poussée eu 5 pour commencer à
contrecarrer le centre blanc qui pour
l'instant est fort et gagne de l'espace
pour les blancs donc petit rock et e5
donc on questionne le centre blanc parce
qu'on a laissé les blancs constituer un
centre assez fort mais c'était
temporaire bien sûr les noirs bon
essayer d'harceler un petit peu se
sentent en tout cas de le questionner
pour voir ce que font maintenant les
blancs on n'est pas encore dans le coeur
de du sujet toujours de l'ouverture
alors que quatre tout ça est normal et
maintenance et 6 alors c'est si c'est un
coût normal alors ces six a pour
objectif de contrôler la classe des ce1
bien sûr et puis maintenant si les
blancs jouent ces cinq on a le choix de
jouer ces 5 alors que si on laisse se
fiancer set et conclue c'est simple qui
a toujours la prise en passant qui est
possible alors que là c'est plus
possible donc en cas de prix pousse
pousse on peut bloquer le centre et
pourquoi pas lancer inactif
une activité pendant sur le centre par
f5 après une fois que le centre est
bloqué on enlève le cavalier en 8es en
plus est simple un peu comme dans les
céciliennes classique on peut aussi
choisir de prendre en d5 sait si c'est
un coup très souple et une grande
souplesse dans l'ouverture autour de 1
tout cela est normal il faut pour les
blancs contrôler fortement le pion aux 4
et le centre tout ça est normal en cas
d'ouverture on a un très beau contrôle
central notamment sur cette case
il faut protéger le pion il faut que ce
qui est important il a un oeil sur sur
des 5
il faut pas que les noirs se libère par
des cinq donc toute pression
supplémentaire sur le centre est bon
pour les blancs il faut avoir des pièces
en soutien hélas le coup suivant et un
coup subtil de des noirs s'ils dame b 6
alors d'un v6 et un coup pour lequel il
faut faire attention puisque il fait un
une attaque sur des cas donc on voit
bien qu'une prise des noirs en d4 déjà
est envisageable et après on prend prise
du cavalier faut pas oublier que le fou
ici est en embuscade
donc on a fouet date donc une sortie de
4,6 pourquoi pas un sacrifice sur quatre
pourrait s'envisager mais en justement
lundi devant la tour que reprendre et le
protège aussi des quatre voilà on
pourrait prendre la tour est protégé
mais en conjonction avec une tour ici
c'est ça marche plus c'est à dire qu on
échangerait tour d'abord et le kari
serait pris donc déjà il ya des idées
qui est qui ont lieu la deuxième idée de
tam des six mais j'attaque b2 donc la
sortie du fou
maintenant n'est pas possible sinon
enfin les possibles mais au prix d'un
pion annoncé ses responsables s'est il
faut fouiller réfléchir deux fois et
enfin une troisième idée pour les noirs
sur ce qu un v6 et devenir aussi en b 4
épis titiller le pion c4 et puis dire
aux blancs mais comment tu protèges ce
pion c'est pas clair parce que si les
blancs jouent b3 et bien ils
s'affaiblissent la grande diagonale
ici les gones alger 7 ici avec ce fou
qui devient extrêmement actif y ait
beaucoup de bailleul cavaliers c3 il ya
la tour en fait d'ailleurs on peut pas
jouer détroit tout de suite il nous
revient c'est dans l'air mais mais si on
joue b3 pour essayer de protéger ses 4
même en ayant bougé ce cavalier mal en
l'ayant le protégé par un coup comme
dame c2 et bien on affaiblit cette
diagonale et ça devient un problème donc
voilà secoué et un coût qui demande aux
blancs d'être précis pour la suite alors
il ya plusieurs réponses à ce coup on
peut tenter des concours aux deux qui
commence à protéger b2 on peut aussi
jouer des coups comme ces cinq ça se
joue dans cette position parce que si
les noirs prennent ans et celle on peut
pour attaquer de l'autre côté en 5
messi joue à plein c'est jouable c'est
ce sont des ouvertures en tout des coûts
tout à fait jouable alors qu'ali à 4,2
car profond le carpaccio choisi une
autre voie
il attaque la dame alors le problème de
secousses évidemment on enlève du
soutien
au centre un mais on dit à la dame dont
on écoute je sais que tactiquement la
petite judith elle sait jouer donc
harper qui l'a pas trop forcément envie
de rentrer là dedans il joue car il ya
quatre ans disant vas t'en ai
effectivement jeudi de s'en va mais
finalement c'est mieux d'avoir joué d'un
v6 car il ya 4 et dames c'est cette que
d'abord je vous donne ses sept tout de
suite
blanc a joué parce que le cavaliere c3
est mieux placé que il ne lui en a
quatre donc la b3 maintenant de la part
de karpov alors b3 a sans doute
maintenant pour idée de jouer four b2 et
d'enlever maintenant toute velléité de
de développement de ce fou g7 ici là
c'est l'affaiblissement et par très
grave puisque on contrôle bien la casse
des quatre en cas de prise prison n'est
bien défendu il n'y a pas de souci voilà
donc deux trois pourquoi pas en plus moi
un jour le métro on protège le cas via 4
mais je vais judith en profite tout de
suite maintenant de cette disposition
puisqu'elle joue le groupe b 5 voilà
alors là réussi son début ça c'est pas
mal parce que maintenant elle menace
d'affaiblir l'ale d'anne parillaud
france et 4 l attaque de cavaliers écart
peaufiner notre idée au sida privé 3 6 2
joue qu'avec les v2 1 je bouge cette
diagonale gens aussi que mon cavalier en
b2 pour essayer de profiter du fait que
je suis à leurs nationaux aura quatre
pas pour rien j'essaie de me recycler
pourquoi pas venir en d3 en faisant
pression sur le pion aux 5
ça peut être aussi une idée est aussi
sur la casse et c'est dingue ce genre
d'idée c'est tout à fait jouable est
aussi une autre idée c'est de en cas de
prise en c4 je prends du cavalier
directement avec un joli cavaliers là
aussi tu y fais pression dans le camp
ennemi donc allée b deux coups car
proviennent ces ça sert aussi d une
finance cash de pièces à la campost
comme il les aime alors là je vous dis
tu joue très bien la suite c'est l'heure
pour elle d'ouvrir le centre b prend ses
quatre cavaliers prendrait quatre
d'ouvrir le centre et aussi la diagonale
du fou g7
parce que là on on voit quand même
quelque chose qui est pas forcément
plaisant c'est un cavalier
un deuxième cas il y ait une tour qui
sont alignés comme ça on se dit qu'il va
y avoir une petite brochette veilleurs
quelque chose à manger un moment
voilà donc c'est un coup c'est un coup
pendant qu'ils jouent pour la tactique
et non pas pour spécialement pour
l'opposition le positionnement assez bon
positionnement sebo tactiquement c'est
un bon coup et la regarder alors je vous
dit qu'ils nous d'attac foulée cette
voie là je laisse karpov prendre en
bessengue et éventuellement après prise
gagner un pion puis et mais j'ai
développé mon four vous allez voir là
l'idée de judith très vite puisque c'est
ce que je vous car pas qui joue s'éprend
b5 en gagnant un pion puisqu'en cas de
prisons reprend alors ça c'est un
désastre un point noir de reprendre
puisque les blancs reprendre et enlevé
cinq attaques la dame et le pion des six
est perdu avec attaque sur le fou non
non c'est pas l'idée de judith regard et
c'est plus subtil cédé 5
voilà ça c'est pas mal je vous dit en
fait n'a pas voulu simplement gagner du
temps et regardez ce fou maintenant il
vit et vie en revanche les cavaliers qui
était au centre va falloir qu'il trouve
une case
voilà c'est pas évident parce que pas
vraiment venir en c6 peut pas venir non
plus bien sûr aussi signaux f5
il pourrait revenir en rêve 3 alors s'il
revient avec trois évidemment il ya un
problème c'est un problème avec le pion
le pion 1 4i perdu tout simplement il
peut prévenir pour les mêmes raisons en
e2 donc en fait il l'objet d'aller en c2
alors voilà karpov va jouer le coup kbc
2 mais en fait secouer passif et il
aurait très bien pu maintenant qu'il a
en fait pris ce pion b celle ci le
cavalier vient en c6 ici il ya un
intérêt à faire ça puisque en cas de
prise du fou on reprend du pied en euros
dans le pion mais on a gagné une paire
de foot puis surtout le fou j'ai deux
souffrent terriblement sur la grande des
ménages il suffit de jouer ensuite sans
qu'on en a tout de suite dit quelque
chose dans la tout de suite du jeu là
dessus imaginons maintenant que les
noirs ce faux sur deux sur fosse
certainement pas prendre ici pas ce
caprice prise alors on peut jouer
curieux 5 éventuellement pour reprendre
ensuite du cavalier et éviter le
vis-à-vis feu dame mais on a donné un
fou de cases blanches donc c'est pas
c'est pas une bonne affaire donc ici
faudrait que les noirs trouve une autre
façon de continuer la partie sans doute
par le cou à 6 essayez de
brisée finalement le soutien du cavalier
alors ça marche puisque sur l'a46 on
peut prendre en est simple le câble est
en prise et on peut pas reprendre du
poids à cause du vis-à-vis tout retour
voilà comment je vous dis tu aurais sans
doute continuer cette brillante
donc c'est prendre des cinq c5 c6 et en
août quand même le meilleur
mais malgré tout karpov peut-être peur
de cette variante avec l'assistant qui
joue le coup cavaliers ces deux bons ici
touré fuite de judith tout à fait dans
l'idée continue de harceler maintenant
le centre on a regardé à l'essai 5 pris
le contrôle de la case des 4 on contrôle
la case de saint-leu fou bessette
maintenant le tape sur les cases
blanches
le cavalier tape sur le gaz et le foot
bessette le foot g7 à un oeil sur deux
pièces ici donc déjà si le fugu gb
lecavalier temps l'air si lecavalier
bouge c'est la tour
donc tout ça est pas bon pour karpov
c'est pour ça que ce dernier cool quand
même trop passif il aurait sans doute
fallu jouer quand même cavalier c6 afin
de boucher
la puissance de ce fou parce que là les
blancs sont dans une position trop
défensive déjà le cavalier le qca très
difficile à défendre la très difficile
d'ailleurs il ne défend pas sic avait
laissé quatre de la part des blancs le
problème de ce coût 1 ce qui fait peur
c'est que évidemment ailleurs et un
vis-à-vis il ya quand même vis-à-vis et
puis on ne protège pas le pian 4 c'est à
dire que là ce pion aux 4 et perdu par
contre on attaque le pion des six voilà
mais le père paul voilà quatre mois que
se venger sur le pion des six dans cette
position donc car il y prend 1,4 quand
même de la patte de la part de judith
mais bien évidemment le problème c'est
que si alors il ya le cavalier qui
protège bien sûr mais c'est une qualité
qui risquent sauté après fou prend 1,4
tour en 1 4 de judith qui se presse pas
eh bien il faut que les
et plan évite la perte de la qualité
donc ici le coup fourré deux voies la
foulée 2 je suis protégé par le cabinet
c4 donc il n'ya pas de problème donc ici
la judith continue sa sa variante vous
allez voir le va s'en sortir avec un
avantage puisque après tout prendre qu à
l épreuve 1 est fou prendre b2 car les
1er 2 c'est l'heure de faire le bilan
la position est favorable noir pour
quelles raisons eh bien d'abord en
termes de pions en à égalité on ya 3 6 6
3 6 3 contre 3 mais on a des seins deux
pions qui sont centraux contre deux
pions qui sont ici plutôt sur le côté
donc ça c'est pas bon on contrôle des
classes centrale et puis de on a un fou
qui est énorme ça c'est très important
puisque ce fou vise les cases du côté on
n'y a plus le foot quasiment jeu pour
protéger
pour l'instant c'est ce cavalier qui
joue le rôle de défenseur garder des
cases c'est le seul vrai défenseur des
cases blanches et avec une position de
ce type là le problème c'est que très
vite il peut y avoir des batteries c'est
à dire que c'est ce qu'on appelle
batterie c'était de remettre la dame par
exemple cette fausse rapprocher le
cavalier puis venir à leucate et comment
par le matin donc les autres cavaliers
qui en 17 6 s'il vient à sauter en 5
l'europe tout de suite un oeil sur la
case f3 qui n'est quand même une case
faible pour les pour les blancs ouais
toujours les cases blanches donc les
cages manche sont faibles les cases mort
de son vers le centre donc tout je lis
tu as réussi finalement son piège
d'ouverture carpreaux fait tomber dedans
il a joué trop passifs comme on l'a dit
tout à l'heure il aurait dû jouer
beaucoup plus actif et boucher l'avenir
de ce fou il n'a pas vu il a mal estimé
dit non il a estimé l'avantagent
positionnelle qui sort de cette
ouverture là et vous allez voir comment
je me dit maintenant va magnifique mans
exploiter sa part et tours 8
alors développement de la tour ça ça
paraît normal colonnes peu qui est prise
et puis surtout on
envisage pourquoi pas de faire un
sacrifice de la tour contre le carrier
parce que on a un fou extrêmement
puissant et c'est le cas puisque après
tout c'est un de karpov qui est logique
aussi ont ils activent sa pièce qui
n'est pas encore acquis l'île très vite
venir
alors il est aussi en attaque il peut
menacer des coups comme b 4-1 qui met la
pression sur sur les pions noirs avec un
clouage ici tour nable et bien c'est
regarder ces magnifiques parce qu'il
faut quand même avoir le cran vous
voulez ça faire il lui dit fait un
sacrifice de qualité positionnelle et
d'attac qui est magnifique tout reprend
cavaliers échec alors on n'a pas le
choix il faut prendre et c'est un coup
dont les conséquences sont difficiles à
calculer concrètement mais un joueur du
niveau de judit polgar voit bien que de
toute façon la puissance de son fou sur
les cases blanches plus le cavalier qui
va entrer dans la position noir je vais
pas dire qui a pas besoin de calculer la
sûrement calculer mais n'est pas
nécessaire d' absolument tout calculer
on voit bien que la situation est
favorable au noir et que les fils de la
perte de la qualité contre à moins que
les facteurs positionne et puis surtout
pia pia lilia pleine grève menace dans
tous les sens y a plein la nacelle à
caprica valeo 5 de judith on voit vite
l'idée d'une itt c'est à dire voilà
effectivement toutes les cases blanches
sont prises le cavalier ne rêve que de
faire une fourchette royal ou de faire
une fourchette dam tour et vous allez
voir comment elle va exploiter ça parce
que derrière l adamo ci peut jouer un
rôle d' attaque donc en fait c'est pas
parce qu'on me donne la qualité qu'on
est moins bien bien sûr c'est pas
toujours le cas des pièces légères qui
contrôlent des cases que ne contrôle pas
l'adversaire peuvent s'avérer plus forte
qu'une simple qualité que nous simples
tours donc d'armes 3-2 karpov et sans le
obligatoire mais sur deux ou trois je
protège à la fois la case f3 et la case
d3 qui est contrôlé par le cavalier mais
regardez d'amd c'est très simple c'est
magnifique on met la dame sur la même
couleur que le foot ou venir ou bâle iii
menée pendant ici il faut que je sois
droit si je viens je crois mais je me
lasse maths et je menace aussi pourquoi
pas de venir prendre le pion des 5
si si si si si possible aussi même si
c'est pas forcément le plus actif mais
si je prends un avion b says je peux
revenir après sur la case ces 6es jeux
menace là encore des matches et on peut
pas protéger parce que des coups comme
froid et bien c'est cavale et prend
toutes les pièces sont sur les cases
blanches à la poussée de le fait que
plonger 3g 2 soit poussé angers 3-1
créer un réseau de caisses faible
impressionnant autour du roi du rhum
blanc et un regarder les pions ils sont
sur noir et donc du coup on n'a rien
pour défendre le cas blanche à noter que
la seule pièce mineurs capable de
protéger le case blanche c'est ce qu'à
valider ce cavalier protège déjà
légalement vous s'il veut venir défendre
il faudrait qu'il joue d'abord en d3
puis en vain pour venir péniblement
défendre deux cases blanches et encore
ça défendrait pas la case à chocs donc
mais celle en tout 16 ans et plus on
peut on peut changer alors carpeaux voit
toutes ces menaces il joue le coup et 4
alors qu'il a l'air de gagner du temps
puisque il attaque le cavalier première
chose est de il peut jouer des coups
comme tour ces deux pour commencer à
essayer de boucher les trous
c'est ça l'idée assez s'est pas laissé
le roi trop isolé mais regardez la suite
damages 3 c1 à ce matin donc déjà le
coût de la taxe sur le cavalier n'ait
amené pas vraiment un il faut protéger
le mat au carpe aux joutes dans me2
alors c'est là qu'on se dit qu'il n'y
aurait peut-être pu jouer dans le double
dames 3 tout à l'heure bien sûr ils
assurent dame de regarder cavalière
trois échecs et c'est fini je fais c'est
fini le roi blanc où il va seller qui on
ne peut pas aller en h1 un peu mes
cavaliers des quatre et on gagne la dame
est chez les fous et donc dame est perdu
donc il ya qu un seul coup on sait déjà
c'est pas bon quand il vous reste qu'un
seul coup on voit f2 regardez déjà pour
la qualité ce qu'on obtient dame prend h
deux échecs et a pris 3,3 d'un projet 3
on a déjà récupéré deux pions elle s'est
déjà remboursé et maintenant il ya deux
options passé le pion des six qu'elle
pions 1,7 ce pion est passé ce pion est
passé ça veut dire quoi passer c'est à
dire qu'il ya pas de vis-à-vis ya pas de
vis-à-vis qui peut empêcher d'aller à
dame donc puis puis la tête continue en
plus apte à continuer exactement donc
après d'alger trois dames f2 dakar pas
il veut essayer de changer les dames il
a bien vu tout ça et je n'y a pas
intérêt parce que regarder laurent blanc
est extrêmement faible
donc elle a intérêt à continuer à garder
ça assez toutes ces menaces est le joug
d'un match 3 très bien d'un match 3 elle
peut menacer de revenir en jeu si ce fut
un échec
éventuellement ton 3.5 pour faire venir
quatre échecs et prendre le dernier pion
f4 toutes les liens et puis menace
l'échec et la découverte le cavalier
peut aller où il veut se fera il choqué
par exemple ils peuvent venir ici il
peut venir là ils peuvent venir dans
plein d'endroits ce cavalier et ça fait
créé un échec de la dame et donc il ya
il ya de gros soucis par exemple un coup
comme calais détroit de carpeaux
seraient punis tout simplement par
c'est le coup la porte insee le coût de
la partie c'est le coup la partie elle
aurait pu jouer simplement car il est 5
heures je pensais bien tout de suite à
l'ajout de choses ici j'avais dit je
vous pas qu'à lui 5
qu'est ce qui se passe ou kaino 5 45
échec c'est un peu parti antonetti en
dit ouais il parle il permet une perte
ou quoi donc d'accord cavaliers g5
en fait c'est ça la joue qu'avec g5
encore mieux oui bah oui parce qu'en
fait le bipper dame différents madame
surcroît des deux puisqu'ils et le four
cholet messi jouera des deux en fait
hyper la dame avec une fourchette
ils vous voient le roi alors on ne peut
pas venir ici on peut pas mettre la dame
en protection puisqu'il ya le cas il ya
le fou donc on est obligé d'aller en
deux elle se régale en fait le moment là
mais en fait alors karpov et sa muse
hussein blitz oui c'est quand même en
fait il aurait pu abandonner
probablement d
dès le magnifique damas trois à damas
trois en fait dès cette position nos
matches trois en fait il n'ya presque
plus de défense après dun de deux
cavaliers chaix et c'est déjà fini
peut-être en partie lente il aurait
abandonné la randonnée mais comme c'est
un blitz y joue encore quelques coups
donc avalé des trois cavaliers cinq
échecs 3e de haut et fort c'est fou et
trois échecs
on peut toujours pas dire en d2
puisqu'il ya toujours le cavalier qui
fait kiffer échec eux et gagne la dame
roi 1 et la cavalier français magnifique
alors là ça regardez c'est beau parce
que le canada 4 attaques la dame et
regarder le problème du roi sait qu'il
est dans un couloir
c'est recoller toutes les cases ici sont
contrôlés par les pièces noires donc le
roi est potentiellement maths par un
coup du couloir donc la dame peut pas
aller n'importe où donc sur dame et fin
simplement ben oui c'est quasiment
seimat quoi c'est c'est horrible
damages quatre échecs y appuyer pas de
coups non il est plus que lecavalier f2
donc il est un échec de matt quasiment
s'il dit mais la dame et il est pris par
le cavalier et il reste que cavalier f2
sur quoi le simple dame prend f4 et ses
abandons parce que regarder on menace à
la fois la tour et mat
alors qu'est ce qu'on peut faire le 5e
le seul coût possible qui parlait de ces
deux joué tour ces deux oui on a un
souci parce que quand même on a toujours
des montois ne me 3 et là c'est fini
qu'est ce qu'on fait non mais la tour on
ne promet de la tour il n'y a pas
d'autres coins il fallait trouver
ensuite oui à ses rhumes dame ses trois
échecs encore si on mène à tour
maintenant c'est matt il reste le coup
roi des huns 3d à me regarder le
problème c'est que la tour maintenant
elle est clouée et suffit de jouer
d'hommes des deux essais match
magnifique superbe un bond à la page où
ça ça ne s'est pas réveillé ce que la
wii que c'est ma force et vous perdre de
la dame
donc après roy deux fois f3 24,84
réforme
mais la met fin à mach 4 km2 dans
première quatre abandons ici de
d'anatolie karpov on voit que la défense
de la tour ne mène à rien cause de dames
trois échecs
c'est superbe magnifique partie avec un
sacrifice de qualité positionnelle qui
donne des résultats quasiment immédiat
avec la force du foot sur les cases
blanches qui était impressionnante
c'est vrai que karpov aurait peut-être
dû ici de bloquer cette diagonale au
lieu de retirer 100 cavaliers en c2
c'était sûrement le tournant de la
partie
exactement donc c'est le style de gide
polgar toutes ces parties sont comme ça
elle cherche absolument le
le déséquilibre dynamique à la fischer
un peu à la carte
anna kasparov avec son style à elle un
style de jeu 8 peut être parfois un peu
trop agressif peut faire penser à talent
aussi sur certains côtés parce que bon
ces attaques sont pas toujours
totalement justifiée et souvent le père
à vapeur des partis parce que parce
qu'elle va être trop optimiste non sur
la table mais alors c'est un plaisir à
voir donc quand on gagne c'est toujours
c'est toujours avec brio avec des
attaques tout à fait improbable donc ca
si les joueuses vraiment à suivre
c'est pour ça qu'elle a beaucoup de fans
et beaucoup de joueurs qui veulent la
voir jouer et pas uniquement parce que
c'est la meilleure féminine du monde
même si c'est aussi un argument c'est un
argument mais les joueurs aiment avant
tout les parties oui et c'est parti
qu'on aime c'est parti qu'on aime de
judith walia la plus grande joueuse
d'échecs de tous les temps voilà merci
pour cette émission cette plongée dans
l'histoire de la carrière de judy powers
qui n'est pas finie est encore jeune
elle peut pas encore faire de très très
beaux résultats
pendant 10 15 20 ans 30 ans le plus et
on aura plaisir mais sur la suivre mais
elle fait déjà d'ores et déjà partie de
la légende du jeu d'échecs par ses
résultats et chicken merci jérôme merci
stéphane et à bientôt pour une nouvelle
émission des gones à tv sur les grands
champions de l'histoire du jeu d'échecs
au revoir au revoir
p